hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I just check it in on you what's going
on let me do that like I'm falling off a
cliff
I woke up this morning badoo badoo by
the dumbest song in my head and I can't
get it out and now I'm gonna sing it to
you so it will be stuck in your head
it's a very vengeful thing for me to do
it's something that you know pieces of
[ __ ] guys do you know if I'm going down
I'm taking you down with me and all
those kinds of piece of [ __ ] you know
they do that the ladies the ladies like
to dabble in that well [ __ ] you this
isn't a relationship at least I'm
getting some of your t-shirts right
they're gonna get something from it well
if this song is gonna be stuck in my
head I'm sorry to say that it's gonna be
stuck in your head too all right and I
have given you a good I've been talking
about this for a good 18 seconds that's
plenty of time even if you're driving in
the car to hit pause and you're choosing
not to why do you do this to yourself
why don't you just choose the road
that's gonna bring you true happiness is
it because you grew up and you watch
people being abused and you felt like
you didn't have a choice in life that
this is the way it was you know what
that last 10 seconds is probably gonna
be worse than the song but here it is
no I hold out my hand and I touch no
it's something it's something huh I
don't know who sings that song I don't
think I've ever gotten past those first
two lines of that song it's always comes
on session presents love songs from the
70s over together this one right ain't
you say they go look at this [ __ ]
horseshit and you start thinking about
your childhood next thing you know
you're on the phone with the operator
can I get the deluxe edition yeah I
still have a CD player in my car well
because I'm frugal
it's not because I'm failing and I
resent you saying that of course I still
want the CDs speaking of my old car my
car I've had it since October of 2007
it's a 2008 Oh was a brand new it had
[ __ ] stars in its eyes right just
stepped off the bus here in Hollywood
with a piece of straw between its teeth
like Axl Rose in the Guns & Roses video
welcome to welcome to the jungle they
now look at it oh this thing it looks
like somebody attacked it with the
[ __ ] can opener
all right it did as until as of the
other day my my wife was out of town she
was in New York City for the great
Patrice O'Neal benefit I want to thank
everybody who came out and I want to
thank everyone who did the show I
unfortunately was not able to get a
[ __ ] flight in in time if you could
believe that I actually missed the
benefit [ __ ] brutal I had a flight
out Saturday morning say and I believe
that when I was on American Airlines and
they just gave me a call do like like
you know we have one 800-number
and I went hello and they were like
hello Lou says oh by record Airlines at
forward you there's like two now
one three has been canceled you've been
relocated no you bite what a grab a pad
you have now bed rebooked on flight
number what seven five zero out of LAX
on Tuesday January 26 at 1:50 p.m. the
benefit was on the 26th I was supposed
to be flying out on the 23rd they pushed
it three [ __ ] days and I was gonna
leave 4:15 East Coast time when the show
starts at 7:00 so I'm like well that's
not gonna work so I called my travel
agent you know and so she got me a
flight on JetBlue 7:45 a.m. on Sunday
the 24th so I'm like no worries alright
so I miss the day no big deal blah blah
blah blah right and then I get a call I
get a call like the night before I'm all
packed I got my [ __ ] right next to the
door and there's like this line from
JetBlue you light whatever bed at a
piece of paper right and then they they
[ __ ] bump me to [ __ ] Tuesday so I
said [ __ ] these guys I called my travel
agent again now I'm on virgin all right
I don't know why they call it Virgin
Airlines and then it looks so dizzy in
that [ __ ] thing it's like if the W
Hotel was a plane you know with the
[ __ ] aquarium lighting that just says
no one wants to see a good look at their
face in a mirror after they do what they
do in here right
so they booked me on that [ __ ] thing
and they're like well the time we can
get you out is right when the New
England Patriots game starts and I'm
like oh my god you got TV [ __ ] it put me
on it right and then that one got
cancelled so at that point I deduced if
I'm using the word properly that that
the [ __ ] every poor bastard from
Saturday and Sunday now that those
flights had all been canceled we're now
eating up all the Monday and Tuesday
ones so I add my travel agent go after
another flight and then meanwhile I
called my manager who knows all these
big guys and I said can you get me a
replacement in case like I'm not gonna
be able to get in long story short I
wasn't able to get in
time we got a replacement and I wish I
could have been there because rich Voss
who crushed it as a host once again this
year and he said blah blah blah
fortunately bill burr can't be here
nobody's like oh what the [ __ ] where is
the red [ __ ] right and he said that's
the bad news he said the good news is
louis c.k and louis c.k walked out and
they went [ __ ] absolutely mental and
you know I was replaced one balding
redhead with another balding redhead
with more credits so nobody missed me
and I guess he [ __ ] murdered it and
then he all you two do is 15 he because
he's such a great guy did like 25 and
just [ __ ] destroyed and everybody had
a great time and somebody sent me a
picture of of everybody in the end
coming out al del bene flew in all the
way from Sydney Australia that's another
reason why I didn't want to reschedule
because this guy flew in from the other
side of the [ __ ] world and who else
was there Rachel finds Feinstein Greer
Barnes who absolutely murdered you know
one of the greatest whoever did it Greer
Barnes Jim Norton I don't have it in
front of me I wasn't there to so I know
I'm gonna end up forgetting somebody but
uh anyways everybody god Freak did it
everybody [ __ ] killed and they had a
great time so anyway so I was out here
and I was supposed to be in New York
from Saturday until Wednesday so nobody
knew that I was out here you know so I
was just like well [ __ ] it I'm not
telling anybody I'm here and I just
started handling a bunch of [ __ ] that
I've been putting off for months if not
years I did everything from get my last
will together might you know when I die
or whatever make sure that everything
goes to the people needs to go to so
there's no fighting hopefully which is
actually it's really morbid but it's
also [ __ ] kind of cool
so I can't [ __ ] you take this and you
take that and I'm out of here
good luck to youse all I had a great
time you had a great ass I rolled change
that we had in jars I handled that and I
dropped my [ __ ] Prius off and I had
all the [ __ ] dents repaired you
should say it looks brand [ __ ] new
there's a couple little ones that they
just stay left in there
they buffed the whole thing up I didn't
get new Pappas because you know you have
new bumpers out here they last for about
three days before somebody just bumps
into him so I just had them buffed those
things up and it looks [ __ ] great
I'll tell you right now having a paid
off Prius with 80,000 something miles on
it in LA is the greatest [ __ ] car you
could ever drive it's just it's the [ __ ]
and it takes the hits
- it's like Ben Roethlisberger it just
[ __ ] shakes them off and it keeps
going and no matter how bad the gas
price is get I've never paid more than
40 bucks a gallon I don't give a [ __ ] if
somebody runs into it I can park it
where ever I want nobody's gonna take it
it's [ __ ] perfect right I bought my
wife a nice car it's nice I can't stand
it I can't you know I feel like when I'm
driving that thing do you met you guys
ever see that [ __ ] hilarious about
Howard Stern's movie private parts do
you remember when he was showing himself
when he first became a DJ and like when
he went to put the needle on the record
and he'd be scratched and he [ __ ] the
whole thing up number that noise he's
making he's going oh that's what I feel
like when I Drive that car like I'll be
going to the grocery store and I'll just
be thinking like goddammit I need to go
in there buy some [ __ ] hamburger but
you know if I don't see a bunch of
wide-open spaces I won't park it in
there cuz I know somebody's gonna come
in and just park right next to it and
[ __ ] open their door right into the
side of it and it's gonna make me
[ __ ] sick you know it's like when you
go to a movie right like right now is a
great time to go see Star Wars maybe in
another [ __ ] week right nobody's
gonna be there you go see a matinee
right it's during the work week you're a
comedian you got a gig that
you say [ __ ] I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go see a matinee showing of Star Wars
[ __ ] six weeks after it came out
right you go in there there's nobody
[ __ ] there you got your feet up you
having a great time it is [ __ ]
inevitable that someone's gonna walk in
during the [ __ ] trailers they're
gonna sit down right behind you and
they're gonna talk a munch popcorn
[ __ ] loudly or they're gonna be
[ __ ] dress like Chewbacca and there's
gonna be getting hair in their mouth
they can be doing that the entire
[ __ ] time it's in that the same the
same way that is inevitable if you park
in a parking lot some [ __ ] even if
there's a bunch of [ __ ] spaces is
gonna pull in right next to you they're
gonna open their [ __ ] do it right
into it you know and that's just regular
people forget about out of shape people
who they gotta like put stress on their
hinges of their doors to just make it
wide enough you know
yeah that's why you know you're fat when
you get like one of those Formula One
[ __ ] steering wheels that just pops
out so you can get your gut out you keep
lying to yourself I'll tell you they
don't make these forward Broncos as big
as they used to yeah they do yeah they
do they most certainly [ __ ] do
so anyways speaking of cars dude I saw
there's somebody up the street man has
got a killer [ __ ] car it's one of
those Volkswagen it's not the bug it's
not the Karmann Ghia it's the [ __ ]
station wagon and they put some white
walls on it and some [ __ ] fog lights
they got the luggage rack on it it's
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ] I love a station
wagon ah sorry I got a little [ __ ]
who's that guy it's as big as a whale
and it's about to set sail hang on Sorry
Sorry I'm singing all these [ __ ]
songs it's a little old place where you
can't get together and do what what kind
of depravity goes on in the Love Shack
there that song even makes sense
they just went out to a Shack and they
[ __ ] I mean maybe I'm taking it too
literally what was I looking up oh yeah
oh yeah the Volkswagen station wagon the
Volkswagen will dissolve Volkswagen
station wagon classic VW station wagon
let's see what this thing's called there
it is
the [ __ ] is it called so I got all the
the pictures of it that's such a [ __ ]
cool car man I love the front end on it
the guy also had it in a stick shift
which i think is a picture below a rear
view of the Volkswagen Beetle from 61 to
767 that's not what I wanted one of
these days one of these days I'm just
gonna look [ __ ] up you know before it
starts and I'll have a nice smooth
podcast I'm imitating my science teacher
from from high school when he was
talking about some sort of biology thing
he said there's there's rough and smooth
I forget what it was and he was like
there's a rough and smooth it used to
make a joke out of it and everybody
would laugh and you'd never get it wrong
in the test yeah you know why there's
not more funny teachers is because they
all become comedians because they're
just like all right I'm basically doing
stand-up here and I'm not making any
money so [ __ ] these kids and their
future Volkswagen Type three squareback
that's all it's called come on they had
to give it a better name than that oh
this is some [ __ ] gearhead think
goddamn [ __ ] bastards can you just
tell me the name of the [ __ ] car
information you think I could look it up
in the Internet by the mid 60s it was
clear that Volkswagens iconoclastic
think small campaign on behalf of the
lowly beetle had succeeded in
transforming the third hike
wait a minute wait what the fuss is
about Hitler I'm trying to read about
the [ __ ] Karmann Ghia is type 2 maybe
there's a Karmann Ghia you know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about you know what
I'll just put a picture up how about
that well I put a picture of that hey
did anybody see Bill Belichick a
football life it was a two-parter
and I gotta admit I was bored shitless I
I've never been more bored watching a
football life even when it was him in
Tom Brady sitting in the office I was it
was [ __ ] egghead [ __ ] but it was just
all monotone just going yeah yeah Lions
have a UH a good defense so uh you know
I put together a game plan and then Tom
Brady to be like smiling but just going
like yeah I thought maybe we could have
the thought running back come on back
feel he could exploit some things uh the
underneath of their secondary oh yeah um
I'm going to look into that okay though
that would be like a scene it was like
[ __ ] even when he got emotional with
the giant stadium I was just like this
is you know eating in a vote motional
like if you want to see the emotional
wide you got to see the dick for me
alone but I was I can't even watch it I
feel like a bad Patriots fan I cannot
get [ __ ] through it maybe I will
eventually so actually there was another
thing I did when I was here I was just
binge watching [ __ ] I watched the whole
first season of top boy on Netflix it's
only four episodes [ __ ] good show man
and I just started the second one last
night and I watched this documentary on
nas who I never got I never got it when
Illmatic came out I was like I don't
like this I don't get it right and now I
went back and listened to it was like oh
wait a minute this is [ __ ]
unbelievable
you got to admit okay when you're
younger there's a lot sometimes there's
albums that come out or artists that
combined you just don't see him because
yeah you know is an older guy like like
David Bowie I never want to see that guy
live and now doing the classic now that
he's dead let me take another listen to
his [ __ ] music and I you know I had
that [ __ ] album like everybody has
that album I had the Ziggy Stardust one
and that's still an amazing [ __ ]
album obviously but it's been played the
death but that was killer
but I downloaded Diamond Dogs and it's
[ __ ] on it's unreal and I was like
how many times could I have seen this
guy I could have seen him on the let's
dance to a list I could have seen him on
any of those and I never did you know
Bob Newhart's playing out Friday night
I'm not gonna get a chance to see him
his [ __ ] show we sold out it's like
way the [ __ ] out in the desert and I got
something 9:30 the next morning so I
can't go [ __ ] see the guy and uh so
I'm trying to make a bucket list of guys
I got to go [ __ ] see I hope they
don't none of nobody plays this for him
because I'm going to see them because
not only I respect them as an artist but
I also I'm afraid they're gonna die you
know I don't have jinx anybody but you
know who they are or even you just want
to see him before they quit touring
right everyone from Tony Bennett to
Stevie Wonder to Bob Newhart to Morton
Downey jr. right
I'm joking I already saw him and he's
dead all right
let's plow ahead I think I got to do a
read for the week here why don't I do
the read and I'll be singing the melody
the one I need love
[Music]
lots of players will be sporting playoff
beats
now that the post seasons here leaf I
can't do the whole thing back to the
pros kick off the year the right way
with a fresh blade shave that's why me
and millions of others have joined the
dollarshaveclub.com revolution Dollar
Shave Club knows that the key to getting
an amazing shape is simple one use a
fresh Dollar Shave Club blade to use
their [ __ ] doctor copies easy shape
that's it
those shake club delivers amazing razors
right to my door for a third of the
price of those greedy mega razor
corporations that means listeners who
switched now could afford the luxury of
shaving with a fresh blade anytime and
save hundreds this year and when you
combine the fresh clean any what you do
if you really want to feel like a rich
guy is get one of those barbershop
chairs and [ __ ] lay back in it and
have one of your drunk friends shave
your face for you don't have them go up
you'll get ingrown hairs and when you
combine that fresh blade with the doctor
cavity is easy it just glides
it's like Lube for your face it's
unimaginably smooth I'm telling you it's
not the average shave shave foam it
won't dry out your skin the all-natural
ingredients
leave your skin feeling soft smooth and
moisturize after every shave take it
from me use a fresh Dollar Shave Club
blade with dr. cabbie is easy shave
butter if you want the the most gentle
shape imaginable join the
dollarshaveclub.com slash burr
revolution today that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash bar high
dollar shave club calm slash burn all
right LegalZoom all right before another
year passes take the time to get your
life organized with Legal Zoom this is
what I've been doing do you have a
family do you have any assets a property
if any of those answers are yes you
should have an estate plan [ __ ] you man
I really did this this is for other
people don't worry if that sounds
complicated Legal Zoom can help yes they
can LegalZoom is a state plan bundles
eliminates the guesswork yes this is
this is a personal testimony you don't
have to figure out on your own whether a
will or living Trucks trust works better
best for you instead you work with an
independent attorney available in most
states they'll walk you through your
options and recommend an estate plan
that offers the best solution to fit
your needs you know it's funny you know
if it's not available
your state they don't think your state
school there's not enough [ __ ] people
for them to make money on like if you're
out there in Wyoming wow I think I'm
doing a gig that coming up and Cheyenne
I got a gig coming up in Denver all
right they'll walk you through your
options and recommend an estate plan
that offers the best solution to fit
your needs
since LegalZoom is not a law firm you
can count on the efficiency and value
everything is your schedule and your
terms plus you'll know what your estate
plan bundles costs upfront instead of
worrying about hourly rates
that's how Legal Zoom has become the
leader in helping small business owners
and families with great with their legal
what with their legal needs you get
legal help and walk away feeling great
there's the great that I was looking at
a [ __ ] line below get your life
organized within a state plan bundle at
legalzoom.com today don't forget to
enter burn in the referral box at check
out that code that's code bar at
legalzoom.com all right there we go and
that's the end of the reads what did I
just want to talk about something in
there reminded me of something
oh yeah the [ __ ] I'm gonna be going
to Denver when I go to Denver they're
either gonna be Superbowl champions or
they gonna be depressed that they lost
but they're probably still gonna give me
[ __ ] that they beat my Patriots but I
got to tell you this man this is pretty
cool do you know Denver's the only team
the New England Patriots have a losing
record - and I know LA do you guys like
[ __ ] a Denver and I'm actually thinking
like I can't believe that's true because
I watched the Patriots before Tom Brady
alright and I think there was very few
people that we had a winning record
against and the fact that who's kidding
who Bill Belichick came in with Drew
Bledsoe and that really started tart and
[ __ ] out and just the way that
they've won over the since like 2000 or
2001 well really like the last 20 years
the way they've won they were let's see
2035 they were 35 years or 35 33 years
in our 32 years in when Drew Bledsoe
took over and Drew Bledsoe took over 20
four years ago so you know that's what
it took it took two and a half decades
to undo [ __ ] three decades of [ __ ]
up and I think that's amazing
now you're probably going well why the
[ __ ] what are the broncos doing you
always got to play in that altitude it
was always snowing and then they had
Craig Morton in the Orange Crush defense
in the 70s and I think before that they
had that Floyd little Greg running back
Randy Gradishar Haven Moses Rick
Upchurch there they always had some
[ __ ] guys and then they got John
Elway in 83 and that [ __ ] after Craig
Morton they went you know a few years
and then 83 Elway came in and that
[ __ ] us from 83 to 98 so even when we
had Drew Bledsoe for the first [ __ ]
six seven years it was against John
Elway who's like top three all-time I
think you know what I mean I'd actually
put him ahead of Peyton Manning
personally personally speaking so I'm
actually excited that there's 32 [ __ ]
teams we're one of them so of the 31
other teams 30 of them we had a winning
winning record against can anybody else
make that claim I don't think they can
all right sorry so anybody watch 60
minutes this past week they did a they
did this feature feature on mountain
lions and now California is the only
state that has mountain lions just
walking around I'm gonna [ __ ] this up in
a park I guess maybe the size of like
Griffith Park or Runyon Canyon or
whatever those ones are out and out in
the valley I guess they have these
[ __ ] things and so anyways I was
watching it because a few of the places
where I hike with my dog and this thing
has intermittently this does this group
of [ __ ] mountain lions has been
around there but fortunately they try to
avoid you I guess at least during the
day if that I [ __ ] hungry but they
showed this [ __ ] these people this
mountain lion
okay they were having some work done so
they had somebody going underneath the
house into the crawl space of their
house and they all right up against this
park and the guy went down there and he
immediately came back up and he was
[ __ ] like white is a ghost and they
were like Don de is you know [ __ ]
white people trying to speak Spanish
right who is it French I don't know and
a guy comes out of the [ __ ] hole was
like yeah but I [ __ ] there's a mount
lying down there I just came faced and I
get out of here you sure are you staff
and they will he's like yeah it's
[ __ ] down there and and so anyways
they interview this [ __ ] la couple
and they had the quintessential [ __ ]
la couple you know what I mean he looks
like the leading man of a b-movie right
she's got like bleach blonde hair she's
wearing fuck-me pumps she's on 60
minutes wearing fuck-me pumps it's
[ __ ] hilarious walking around done up
to the nines and I actually it was
pretty cool I was trying to figure out
where the house was I google mapped it
and I think I was able to find it but
[ __ ] this state is so [ __ ] insane
with the droughts the fires the
rattlesnakes the coyotes the mountain
lines you know and everybody's in this
place is so phony and so plastic well
you know it can get that can all go away
pretty damn quick with the wildlife I
mean it's sort of like a [ __ ]
Australia like like super light you know
what I mean
as I was throwing that out there I just
heard everybody down there awful Oh give
me a [ __ ] Breno flipping out about
how dangerous they're [ __ ] you know
how dangerous Australia is let me tell
you something right now there's no
[ __ ] snakes in Sydney Australia
all right there's all that shits in the
middle of their [ __ ] country
everywhere there's some at the zoo right
every once in a while you'll see
somebody you know goes to pick up a
snake thinking it's a garden snake
you just [ __ ] bit there goes jogging
and it races through his veins and he
[ __ ] dies yes that does happen but
you know people done you know what let's
let's actually let's look up some stats
here let's go to the stats there because
I don't think you're gonna hear enough
stats between now and the Superbowl you
know as they sell the game the upstart
new talent Cam Newton with his whole
career ahead of them coming up against
the Wiley that's one plate and Lanigan
who went to germany and god knows what
happened but he's not on the Patriots so
ESPN's not gonna cover it I'm not I
didn't think he did anything but you
know but the accusation was out there I
mean it came from Al Jazeera I mean who
knows more about NFL football than Al
Jazeera Al Jazeera all right what the
[ __ ] was I looking up all right
snake bite deaths Australia comes right
up this is all touristy [ __ ] like am I
gonna die if I go down there snake bite
deaths 2015 list of fatal snake bites in
Australia gotta love the internet I'm
not saying the informations right but
they always have an answer all right
snake bite del East the Eastern brown
snake is responsible for about 60% of
deaths caused by snake bite in Australia
all right here's the numbers the 2010
all right in 2015 there was one one
brown snake or Taipan
species is unconfirmed you know why cuz
a snake left didn't hang out like yo I
did that [ __ ] like the little fountain
it's a snake you get it I'm sorry
in 2014 there was two right that's big
bad dangerous [ __ ] in Australia let's
check out the US when Andy [ __ ] hello
United States
list of fatal snake bites in the US all
we got to do is be one one ties it it
goes into overtime in the 2010 one two
three four
go [ __ ] yourself Australia Paula hello
how FAR's 39 year old female a green
Mojave rattlesnake Russell E Davis 39
Jesus 39 was an unlucky year timber
rattlesnake you wanna hear the story
Dave was sitting around the fire at his
family's camp when he was bitten by a
rattlesnake Jesus Christ in the balls
right in front of his whole family he
was taken to the hospital and from there
airlifted to a Pittsburgh area hospital
while enroute the helicopter Davis
suffered a cardiac arrest I Jesus grant
Thompson 18 male a Cobra
who the [ __ ] has a Cobra you get hit by
a car
wait Thompson was found unresponsive in
his car in North Austin Lowe's in North
Austin at a low store parking lot
how the [ __ ] do you get by a a monocled
Cobra oh it's got the one [ __ ] glass
on it to what little I grasp the classic
it was evil like it's a James Bond
villain all right it's a Cobra species
which is widespread across the South and
Southeast Asia
oh Jesus somebody [ __ ] ordered one a
monocle Cobra that he was known to own
was missing and was later found dead
near by having been run over by a car
wait a minute I I'm sorry we got we got
to get to the bottom of this [ __ ]
story so this [ __ ] kid ordered a
goddamn Cobra wait a minute
do one of these people gonna [ __ ]
love them let me let's let's not get
crazy here let's let's find out what
happened to this kid Jesus Christ grant
Thompson grant T hom Thompson Cobra
alright grant Thompson committed suicide
by allowing a Cobra this is the most
this can't be true
suicide by snakebite question mark is
this clickbait I was gonna say this kid
looks just like Lance Bass and it was
actually clickbait on the side says
Lance Bass shows us the most expensive
item from his wedding registry isn't
that a little disrespectful to have next
to this kid alright so the kids sitting
here with the parrot from one of his
like was Baretta parrots police
investigate Texas teens death after he
leaves a cryptic message on Facebook
that that's death of a Texas teen who
was killed after being bitten by a cobra
last Tuesday he's being investigated as
a suicide Austin police confirm two
people who's his People magazine yeah
they're indifferent to what people are
doing grant Thompson was found
unresponsive 'el inside his car in a
Louis parking lot last week with
puncture wounds to his wrist and a snake
cage beside him kW TX reports he was
discovered surrounded by a large by a
number of animals including a non
venomous snake six tarantulas and a frog
but his pet Cobra was missing this was
in his [ __ ] car Thompson was rushed
to blah-blah-blah where he later died
yeah I don't think in Austin they're
gonna have [ __ ] for a cobra unless they
got a zoo nearby right it was located I
love a police believed that Thompson
committed suicide by allowing the
venomous snake to bite him surely before
he was found Tuesday the team posted a
cryptic message to his Facebook page
writing I'm sorry Thompson's family owns
a pet shop
Temple Texas he'd worked for the store
most of his life he could handle
tarantulas like they were kittens he
loved animals and loves spreading
awareness about animals in the community
nops Topsy was performed Thursday but
authorities are waiting for the tux at
what tough [ __ ] Jesus dude that is
hardcore you ever heard those things
there is nothing like the hiss of a
[ __ ] reptile and that [ __ ]
reptilian look like what other look are
they gonna have in that face
how is Lance Bass reverse aging Jesus
Christ [ __ ] teeth alike does he even
eat anything his teeth are like
brand-new like out of the box all right
I think it's time to wrap this up wrap
it up I'll take it
wait a minute where the [ __ ] am I here
where's the rest of this [ __ ] Jesus
Christ bill what are you doing
all right that's not it is this it
that's not it that's the [ __ ] about my
will I don't know what this is and I
don't know where everything went I give
up [ __ ] it anyway so that's the end of
the podcast Jesus Christ my condolences
to anybody knew that kid holy you know
what are the odds for there's no way he
was covered for that huh and your
[ __ ] insurance accidental death
accidentally getting bit by a cobra in
the wrists in the parking lot of a
Lowe's in Austin Texas all right anyways
that's the podcast I hope you guys have
a great weekend and stay away from the
snakes so you know what Australia
alright that was deliberate so we can't
count that one so we had three times as
many deaths as you did so why don't you
tone down how [ __ ] nuts your status
or your country whatever it is right
Island you know it's not that [ __ ]
dangerous you know what it is we buy
into it because of the [ __ ]
the shrimp on the barbie guy Paul Hogan
and then the Crocodile Hunter you know
and when you really think about it out
of the Crocodile Hunter died was it one
of those snakes that he was constantly
[ __ ] with was it any other the land
animals that he was constantly [ __ ]
with it was not he [ __ ] with the
Stingray and he forgot that those things
always are armed they always have a
shank he got stuck right like a [ __ ]
prisoner has enough time going by that
you can actually address the foolishness
of that death like let me [ __ ] go
just jump on the back of a stingray you
know and I'm not talking about the
Corvette people I'm talking about the
actual [ __ ] fish you gotta watch that
tail it'll stab you in the heart you
swim to the surface and pull it out
sorry anyways that's that's the podcast
for this Thursday afternoon have a
wonderful weekend you [ __ ] my
condolences to that kid in the Lowe's
parking lot in to the Crocodile Hunter
ain't even a Paul Hogan you know I don't
know what he's up to I hope he's got a
new hat though you know nice new fresh
hat and with that here's a little bit of
music from Andrews emili´s and a little
bit of throwback podcasts from from a
year going on
[Music]
I'm not crazy like my brother but it's
true
without you I don't hang around with the
search level when I got everything to
lose would y'all bring them up
it's
and all that I was worth
I was
don't you be a passerby
say
and that is it bill
bit of a dilemma here for you I'm an 18
year old male who's about to graduate
from high school congratulations
over the past few years I've been told
I'm a really good dancer not ballet or
artsy stuff but just good dance floor
dancing oh my god I'm gonna take over
the dance floor hey Angie
watch me you're John Travolta this is
great do you go out to the Staten Island
bridge and do head stands with you with
your buddy Bobby huh you know if he
didn't have an afro he never would have
fell off that bridge if you had it high
and tight like all these Armenians out
here all every Armenian looks like they
know that they know MMA moves last time
you saw an arm Armenian dude in his 20s
or 30s and he did not look like he could
put you in an armbar within two seconds
if he wanted to
if I would if I was Dana White and I was
running the UFC at one point at this
point what are they're up to like what
like UFC 2006 you know they're like
running they've run out of adjectives
this time it's really really personal
right not saying I'm not a family huge
[ __ ] fan I'm just saying you know the
way they have those things like every
other week there's only so many like you
know redemption I mean you've running
out of words this is what I would do if
I was dating white at some point I would
have you know you know what this is what
I would branch off and where they had
those tough man competitions and they
would have just people coming in
throwing haymakers which is some of the
best boxing ever is when you watch
people who just aren't trained
whatsoever and they just start you know
cuz somebody's gonna connect right I
think that they should have one week
they should have the Armenians versus
the Russians tough man competition
because I really think that that means
it needs to be decided
who is the tougher of the two because
more night when it comes to white people
that's that's who I got my money on all
right that those those are the Crips and
the Bloods of white people is the army
and the Russians all of them
they just have that vibe there's
something you just like I'm not [ __ ]
with that guy just really I'm really not
doing it anyways not a ballet or artsy
stuff but just ballroom dance and a
[ __ ] dance and over here I kind of
think of think dancing is gay from an
outside point of view it isn't it really
isn't that's just how white people look
at it it's considered gay because it
involves like letting yourself go and
actually admitting that you have
emotions as a man as a white male yeah
it's can see yeah it is it's considered
gay as is crying as is showing any sort
of emotion as is not dying for no good
goddamn reason before you 56 oh not
dying I should say if you live to be 60
I believe in once white men that's also
considered gay because that means at
some point you cried something out of
your chest and you didn't have a heart
attack anyway he says I think dancing
his gay from an outside point of view
but I'll be the first one to admit that
I'm actually a pretty good dancer
if I didn't think so I wouldn't be out
there doing it yeah but dude you got to
be getting something oh oh [ __ ] women
love a guy who can dance dude if you can
dance and you're wearing like a silk
scarf it's [ __ ] over it's gonna be
raining [ __ ] as far as my outside view
my freckled view from over in the bar
trying to stand up from underneath those
hot lights so I don't get burnt
you know redheads were the closest thing
to vampires you know we have we have
none of the powers of vampires but the
Sun affects us the same way a friend of
mine who is a female dancer keeps
telling me I could make money doing it
on commercials or music videos
parenthesis clothes on or you could go
to [ __ ] Broadway and be like one of
the five straight men who dances on
Broadway and just tag every [ __ ]
lonely chick out there who's all
stretched out just make sure you keep
their shoes on dancers feet are always
[ __ ] up here's where it gets
complicated I plan on becoming a
policeman
oh dude this is this is a no-brainer you
need to dance at bachelorette parties
dressed as a cup all you need do is that
a fake uniform in a boom box and you're
on your way to making money
dude you should [ __ ] do that in a
second and then you write a book about
it I was a gyrating cop for bachelorette
parties and you write a tell-all book
about how many [ __ ] broads who bought
really got married
good get married suck your dick you
really need help on this one
I mean I'm gonna read the rest of it but
I think I've already come with the
solution anyways how is anyone supposed
to take me seriously on the force if
there's a video going with me pop and
locking next to little Wayne at the same
time I'll dude you should [ __ ] pull
people over you should pull people over
and [ __ ] moon walk up to their car
and just freak him out even they'll
reach for a gun they'd be laughing too
hard and they they they wouldn't shoot
you then you could arrest them and then
you move up next thing you know you're a
commissioner right
nothing anyways at the same time I'm
getting laid a lot because of it of
course you are I'm a seven on a scale of
ten I like this guy he's honest and I'm
and like having a jump shot it's put me
up to an eight-five I'm banging tents
I've always wanted to be a cop but the
parks here seem better if I was able to
make money doing it other than the
dancing thing I wouldn't just be getting
Hummers for letting gross moms off on
speeding tickets I could be banging JLo
she's into dancers right thanks yeah
dude abso-fucking-lutely dude you're
basically saying what should I do here
should I bang J Lo's be down at the club
and make all this [ __ ] money or
should I take a job where I'm gonna get
shot at and not be appreciated you know
I'll tell you every cop out there would
dance if they could as opposed to being
a cop I don't care if they'd like seven
generations in dude this is what I think
of as far as like dancing I think if I
if I like compared it to being a
comedian oh the open mics would be
getting a piece of park cardboard and
being on a subway platform making money
that way
and then when you move up to hosting a
show that would be your dress as a cop
and you [ __ ] dance at bachelorette
parties that's what you do on the side
that's like you [ __ ] day job that
[ __ ] and then during the day yeah I
would try out for those [ __ ] I don't do
they make music videos anymore or
[ __ ] uh I don't know believe it or
not I don't know how to climb the ladder
as a dancer but dude abso-fucking-lutely
if you can make money doing that [ __ ]
and then what the great thing is is once
you get to a certain level to to make
more money you know once you got some
credibility you can you always have the
fallback where you can teach your class
they can you can be like I danced for
nine years and Chitty Chitty Bang Bang
and [ __ ] banged every [ __ ] broad
on there and then if you'd like to know
how to [ __ ] the women in your cast while
still not losing your job come on down
the Frankie's [ __ ] dance studio
whatever just you'll figure it out as
you go in there and yeah absolutely
absolutely I would definitely do it you
want to do it he wouldn't taken the time
to write in so your big fear should be
whatever but everybody's big fear is
like what if I [ __ ] go after this
dream and I'm 30 and I'm sleeping on a
[ __ ] futon and it hasn't happened yet
well I got to tell you something sir
I've been there I was there at [ __ ]
34 I was still sleeping on a futon and a
[ __ ] studio apartment that they
called a one-bedroom because they
slammed a [ __ ] wall in there and put
a door on it and then one day I was
trying to bang the girl upstairs who had
the [ __ ] apartment right above me and
it was the exact same unit and hers was
a studio but she had been there longer
so they never slammed a wall in there
and I realized hey wait a minute I'm
getting [ __ ] you know I should go down
there and try to get some money taken
off this I should go down to the they're
[ __ ] me over rental board but I
didn't I said [ __ ] just keep writing
jokes right so whatever all you got to
do you just got to commit to this [ __ ]
and and then realize that you know sleep
on a futon when you're 30 is not the
worst thing it isn't you don't see what
you know it's worse than sleeping on
futon at 30 sleeping in a king bed next
to a [ __ ] woman you
really in love with but for some reason
married and you got a couple of kids and
you got a job that you [ __ ] hate okay
you'll be laying there fantasizing about
[ __ ] sleeping on a on a futon there
there's no risk when you go after a
dream it's all [ __ ] reward it's all
gonna lead to something good it always
does
there's a tremendous amount of risk to
playing it safe and that leads to
unbelievable levels of regret which is
something else I've also experienced
because I'm an old [ __ ]
[Music]
I heard her to say
watch it shine
a passerby
[Music]
Oh
this is entitled afraid to break up with
girlfriend
I'm gonna read slow so this takes up as
much time as possible hey Bill I'd like
to get your advice on something I've
been dating my girlfriend for almost a
year now and I've been thinking about
breaking up with her
well it's time to break up with her sir
all right been dating her for a year you
know yet still you thinking about
breaking it it's time okay I says we get
along fine and we rarely argue I was
just thinking of a great boy a great way
to break up with someone they should
invent like a breakup suit right just
something where you just cannot get
injured and you just put the thing on
with the [ __ ] helmet you don't wear
the helmet you just put the onesie zip
up on and which totally protects
everything right and then you get in the
passenger seat you let her drive let me
drive did you just drive tonight but you
always like to drive
honey you just drive okay why are you
wearing that suit it's all gonna make
sense in about five miles all right you
get out on the [ __ ] highway you just
start talking to her and out of no way
he just put the helmet on you know and
she says what are you doing and just say
listen I don't want to go out with you
anymore and then she goes what and you
go hey watch this and you just open the
door and you roll out of the [ __ ] car
that's it you're out you know type up a
fake police report you tell them that
you died then she feels bad for you not
to deal with any sort of repercussions
anyways he says we get along fine and we
rarely argue but I'm starting to realize
I don't really want to be with her for
the long haul we started dating she
[ __ ] thing these iPads suck by the
way all right you know that iPad is it's
it's a [ __ ] laptop for [ __ ] what's
the matter your laptop is too heavy you
[ __ ] douche bag this thing doesn't
have a keyboard it's got nothing you
think that they don't know how to make
this thing into a [ __ ] laptop already
of course they do this is the Steve Jobs
way of doing things rather than just
giving you the whole [ __ ] thing he's
gonna give me ten increments like a
goddamn drug
you know that's why I haven't bought one
of these yet
this is Nia's by the way borrowed this
[ __ ] thing and I am NOT enjoying it
as you can tell as I'm throwing a temper
tantrum here you know when I'm gonna buy
a [ __ ] iPad I'm gonna buy it when it
is a laptop when it is a little light
laptop until then I'm not I'm not having
this [ __ ] this this is like a this is
like when you you know you go you know I
really want to get the new Camaro and
then you get the one with the v6 engine
rather than getting the full-out one
with the stick shift which is a laptop
right it's too heavy you know [ __ ]
deuce deuce shoulders at the gym next
time you do that okay maybe do that
maybe to do some stuff to build up your
wrist oh god bill can you get through
the question alright I will he says we
first started dating I loved hanging out
with her but I'm just not into her
anymore does that make me an [ __ ] no
it doesn't why would your own true
feelings make you an [ __ ] sir how
awful were your parents
he says I'm 23 years old with the
somewhat why am i you know so I'm really
being a [ __ ] this week this guy's asking
for my advice let's try to bring the
anger down bill you're frustrated it's
[ __ ] hot in here
you can't open the window because you
say [ __ ] too much this building's a
co-op and they'll kick you up okay
that's what's going on here it has
nothing to do with this person okay it's
once you just try to be a nice guy so I
should have done off the mic like I'm
scolding myself just try to be a nice
guy but it's not take out your bad day
on everyone else okay you're
embarrassing me
all right I'm 23 years old there's
somewhat of a decent job and really just
want to go back to being single for a
while
exactly dude you're 23 years old dude
you're [ __ ] movie star at that age I
don't care what you're doing for a
living should definitely be single I
said the problem is she's got a lot less
she's got a lot of stress in her life
right now not your problem she's
finishing nursing school and trying to
find a job alright well tell her to put
on the outfit banger one more time and
hey watch this you bail out of the car
um anyways he says oh and she has a
history of depression over the past year
I feel like she's becoming emotionally
dependent on me
like I'm keeping her going or something
well Jesus Christ no wonder you want to
get rid of her you don't want this you
know you want something that someone
that's gonna be fun to be around you
want her you know sunny out she looked
like it's raining out the [ __ ] head
under the pillow one of these days you
know you stay with that long enough one
of these days you're just gonna it's
gonna smother with that pillow anyway so
how do I go about breaking up with her
while causing the least amount of damage
he said also she always leaves some of
her [ __ ] in my apartment yes because she
she wants to [ __ ] she's clinging on
to you
he says clothes blanket other random
[ __ ] I try to get her to take a [ __ ]
home with her but how do I avoid after
the after breakup coming over to get my
stuff I hate that anyway go [ __ ]
yourself alright look there's no way
there's no easy way to break up with
somebody
alright there's just easier ways the
sooner the better
[Music]
dinah'll dude this is Lisa's like
dismantling a bomb so you know what you
would like to do is say hey can you come
by today I want to talk to you about
something right sure I'll be right over
and then immediately just take out a box
put all of her [ __ ] in it tape it up and
then she rings the bell Bing bong you
open the door you got ya don't a date
you anymore you just handed the box and
closed the door right dude there's money
to be made in this man does anybody have
a professional breakup service that's
such a [ __ ] thing to do but that would
be phenomenal you know you feel you make
your person feel like they got fired you
like what a corporation fires you and
just two security people show up you
know confiscate your computer and then
escort you out of the building would
that be great do this what you should do
just hire two your friends to dress up
like security guards tell her you want
to break up you know and then they have
all her [ __ ] in the box then they escort
escort aright out of your
apartment building like she got fired it
come off as professional rather than
like personal how do you go about
breaking up with it you know what I
would do
I wouldn't put all this [ __ ] in the box
cuz that's gonna come off cold you know
and you don't want to hurt her feelings
like that so I would just oh [ __ ] it I
don't know I don't know how to do it why
did I drink last night and then I got up
and did open Anthony what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me I knew I had a podcast to
do um I don't know [ __ ] though just
haven't come over and just say listen
I'm not happy oh that's a great one
that's a classic you know like if you
were a singer-songwriter the second he
said that the whole crowd would start
applauding recognizing the big hit you
know above all the girls I do before you
know they all start [ __ ] clapping you
know if they just came out you just did
classic breakup monologues listen I'm
just not happy everyone just that
smattering of applause you wait for it
to die down
let the orchestra come around again you
jump back in on the one man still you're
not happy I'm gonna happen anymore
and dude let me tell you something her
being depressed is not your [ __ ]
problem all right
her being depressed is the [ __ ]
problem how can you do this to me what
do you mean how can I do this to you
don't be words if I [ __ ] stayed with
you and I didn't love you I don't love
you anymore I don't love you depressed
[ __ ]
I just called you a [ __ ] as a generic
term you know I don't I'm not happy I
want out okay I just feel like I want to
be single right now I just don't feel
like I'm gonna be with you in the long
haul we'll just be wasting each other's
time my time is important and so is
yours all right I don't want to go
anymore but I'll tell you what if you go
to stamps.com they'll give you $55 free
stamps and a scale that's what you do
just tag every mean thing you say with
all the advertising you know if you go
to amazon.com screw bilborough's website
you know click on the little amazon
banner whatever you buy
you know portion of that money goes back
to bill burr and then the percentage of
that goes to the Wounded Warriors
Project so I know I'm breaking up with
you right now but you could we could
also support the troops right sir look
there's no [ __ ] easy way to do this
and you're gonna be sitting there
how many more holidays how many more
birthdays how many more Christmases
which is a holiday sorry
you always need three examples do you
want to go through with this person how
many more times do you want to go out
and rent bikes go to a picnic sit there
on a sunny day is she sitting there with
that cloud over a [ __ ] head you know
don't you know don't do that to yourself
you might have [ __ ] people who are
just wonderful human beings and they
just end up with [ __ ] I swear to god
[ __ ] they look for wonderful human
beings because other [ __ ] are not
gonna put up with them you know so you
need to be an [ __ ] here you know the
the how society looks isn't as an
[ __ ] like you're being selfish not
being selfish
all right choose yourself choose your
own [ __ ] life dumper and get on with
your life
you know this is what you do you get
yourself by six a [ __ ] Pale Ale or
whatever beer you like you stick a
couple of glasses in the [ __ ] freezer
all right like anticipation of this
championship that you know you're gonna
win you know like they did in the Red
Sox dugout when they had the champagne
on ice in Game six in 1986 before they
had to quickly wheel it out okay except
you're not gonna let this one go through
your leg sir
you're kicking this one right in the
[ __ ] and you're taking home the [ __ ]
championship and when it's over all you
got to be just thinking about those
frosty [ __ ] bruise in the fridge just
think about that just look at the clock
when she walks in all right let's say
she comes in at ten past two just say to
yourself worst-case scenario
buy three [ __ ] 30 I'm gonna be
sitting down on this [ __ ] couch all
right with my goddamn phone off drinking
a couple of five or six of these things
then that's it
all right and then don't [ __ ] have a
post breakup sex don't do that because
then she'll think that you're back
together again [ __ ] all of that all
right I gotta come by and get my stuff
okay when you want to come by this is
coming off really cold she's gonna do
all of that and just try to keep
dragging you back into the [ __ ] thing
I don't know if this is a punk thing to
do but after you break up with her just
don't answer the phone when she calls
and then she'll find just say listen I
gotta I gotta come by get my stuff can
you text her back a [ __ ] just be a
man what is she gonna do
bodyslam yeah she's just gonna make you
feel bad
all right no it's cuz you're a mope E
you sucking the life out of me you know
when when you get that sad look on your
face you look like a muppet there I said
it
all right there's your [ __ ] over there
in the corner I got a couple of cool
ones in the fridge so I want you do me a
favor all right
get over there bend down lift with your
knees get your [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out
of here
what do you say that it's your Prince
Charming is out there somewhere you know
and ain't here I'm not riding that horse
anymore okay I just shot it in the back
of the head it's over okay so once you
trudge on out of here they have [ __ ]
Cinderella go look at a mirror go climb
up in a tower and [ __ ] drop your hair
out whatever the [ __ ] he's supposed to
do kiss a frog alright I got drinking a
different bait it something like that
like I said all that [ __ ] I said ten
past two it's over by 3:30 by 3:30 you
boozing all right
now they [ __ ] brutal breaking up
assemblies bro nice brew those just
awfulness at this [ __ ] podcast but
other than that
[Music]
I don't know I've been all over the map
politically but it's white like you know
certain ways of looking at [ __ ] like
when people talk about guns let's just
make them let's just make them illegal
and then nobody will have them you know
like that sort of like thought process
is you're you're acting as though the
world is a utopia and that there's not
morons and that there's not people who
say I don't give a [ __ ] what the rules
are you're totally not even taking into
consideration sociopaths which is why
that new [ __ ] thing that Obama signed
that whole defense package where now
they can just arrest people without a
trial JIT and put you in jail forever
with without a trial because they just
think you're a [ __ ] terrorist you
can't give people that level of power
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I know you can't
do that historically no one has ever
handled that level of power well anybody
here want to go live in China are we out
there practicing your nunchucks wearing
your wooden slippers and all of a sudden
a van pulls up when you disappear and
that's it forever you want to live that
course you don't you want to live here
where they can't [ __ ] do it well they
can do it now you know they just put in
a [ __ ] order for a bunch of black
vans that's what I heard
according to holy [ __ ] calm that's
what's going down I don't understand why
stuff at that level that affects
citizens to that level why we don't get
to vote on it do you think it's because
we'd say hey you know what [ __ ] that do
you understand like that is just a jump
off point do you think like that's just
how it's gonna stall so you know you
think it's just gonna stop with that
that's not how you take away freedom you
don't just [ __ ] do it all in one fell
swoop it's incremental it's just like
when you're dating some [ __ ] woman
you're not paying attention and she just
gradually everyday takes another foot of
real estate next thing you know you're
in Gold Line D going how the [ __ ] that I
end up in this situation we started at
the 50 little push little pole right
everything was fine next scene oh you're
up against the goal line you think that
they're just gonna keep it with the
terrorist thing
you know you know the weights for a
whole nother generation of babies to be
born and they always grew up with
government having that level of power
then they add something else to it then
they add something else then that's it
you can't have it okay if Tiger Woods
can't handle the level of free [ __ ] on
a golf tour how the [ __ ] is our
government gonna handle a new defense
package which basically gave them a mute
button when you love - how would you
handle that if you had that power do you
how long before you just started abusing
that if you could just hit mute on
anybody who ever disagreed with you and
then just you could have them whisked
away I mean that is the sociopaths wet
dream that's what that is that is a
[ __ ] mute button mr. Stalin don't you
think that's it yet mute you're done you
gone see you I think I think it's it's
[ __ ] insane and the only thing that I
get out of it is that I feel like I was
proven correct that I don't think it
matters at that level whether you vote
democrat or republican Obama the first
black president ever you would think
this would be the most liberal
politician in the history of this
country because of his background you
would think that he signed off on that
[ __ ] all right
I'm telling you I don't know what
happens when you become president but I
think they let you peek just enough
behind the curtain and you did there is
a [ __ ] agenda that we are moving
towards because it does I don't think it
[ __ ] matters I really don't which is
why I always vote for the Ralph Nader
the [ __ ] Ron Paul all those guys that
all those [ __ ] idiots go to because
you did that you've ruined the election
really did I I feel like those guys
wouldn't have signed [ __ ] like that I
feel like their track record shows that
they would not sign [ __ ] like that
I don't know I have no I imagine I'm
gonna get a ton of [ __ ] emails I mean
was somebody was yelling at me one time
saying that because I voted for Ralph
Nader in 2000 that's why George W Bush
won and they were just going on and on
and on about it and I was like dude I
live in New York Al Gore won my state
okay you understand that so your whole
[ __ ] theory right now is out the
window I voted for Ralph Nader in New
York and Al Gore still won the state so
go [ __ ] yourself what I'm trying to do
I'm mr. [ __ ] red and blue tie here I'm
trying to [ __ ] encourage more people
like that to vote so mission
accomplished that's what I'm trying to
[ __ ] not to vote to run you know
uncorruptible how far can you get if
you're uncorruptible I would say that
you can get to the whatever level
politics is when you decide whether or
not they should put a gazebo in the
center of town I think Pete once you get
beyond that you got it you got to be a
little dirty right I love talking about
this [ __ ] cuz it just stirs people up
you know you know maybe should I'll read
a little more before the next time you
[ __ ] um really what are you reading
huh what are you reading what they give
you is that what you're reading [ __ ]
why are you acting like you have
clearance to the bottom floors of the
[ __ ] Pentagon you're guessing just
like I am all right mr. informed I read
the pamphlet I don't buy a [ __ ] word
of it you know you can use coca-cola to
take rust off of metal you can use it
for that you know you understand that
yet they're still able to sell it to us
like it's refreshing
I don't know at that point men either
[Music]
little Jackie ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]